nous allons avoir des samedis 23 un
concert d'ouverture avec jean marie
ragald chaque darbo jimmy desvarieux et
jean-luc guanel le parrain de notre
manifestation avec le groupe indie ce et
nous invitons toutes les personnes qui
souhaitent y assister à s'inscrire
puisque de toute façon pour y accéder il
faut avoir le pass d'entrée donc vous
allez sur la page facebook de notre
festival festival international du zouk
martinique et vous aurez toutes les
informations attention des inscriptions
c'est jusqu'à demain midi
nous avons une conférence mardi qui est
sur le sujet de l'identité zouk et de
son impact économique et touristique en
martinique
nous invitons toutes les personnes qui
se sentent concernées par cette part ce
sujet de nous contacter à sol et âtre à
2,0 l atr
@ gmail point com pour nous demander
leur invitation il leur contrée pour ce
conflit de cette conférence le zouk ça
marche ça marche
nous avons l'impression que ça marche
plus à l'extérieur qui sait et puis nous
avons trop mendiant au niveau du zouk
nous avons
un ressenti c'est à dire que le zouk
c'est notre petite musique que nous
faisons pour entre amis quand on danse
on va danser en boîte et cetera mais il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont pas
encore compris que le hockey est une
vraie richesse musicale à une vraie
richesse au niveau de ses textes surtout
de la l'époque de patrick saint-eloi et
tous ces artistes qui sont un petit peu
de la même époque
ça ne veut pas dire que le zouk de
mètres n'en ai pas mais pas bon mais on
a en a une autre c'est vraiment
l'essence même du zouk et il nous
remarquons que à l'extérieur que ce soit
au japon en afrique et ben tous ces pays
joue notre musique apprennent nous nos
chansons ici et nous n'apportons pas la
même importance à notre musique ici que
peuvent le faire les autres concerts
aussi le tourisme l'économie tout à fait
puisque en fait l'identité de la
martinique c'est sa culture et c'est
bien de faire des événements pour les
martiniquais
c'est encore mieux de faire des
événements pour être une vitrine pour
d'autres notre notre île est justement
ces pays qu'ils aiment notre musique
faire un événement à l'avenir qui
pourrait nous permettre de faire venir
toutes ces personnes pour pouvoir être
au coeur même de la culture zouk
alors nous avons fait le choix de chiens
pierre parce que nous avons eu un
soutien de la collectivité qui qui est
immense une écoute un partage un travail
en commun sur ce projet et
c'est une ville qui a compris la mesure
de cet événement et qui nous ouvre à
chaque fois grand les bras pour pouvoir
accueillir notre événement et faire en
sorte que chaque année il soit encore et
toujours mieux